[Applause]
its toppling caused reverberations
worldwide
by the end of sunday the 7th of june
2020 the statue of slave trader edward
colston that had stood for more than 125
years
was at the bottom of bristol harbor
today four of those protesters were
found not guilty of criminal damage
i'm just so overwhelmed because it never
felt like we got we'd get here and now
we're here and this is we just want to
say thank you to so many people because
we have never been alone in this journey
we didn't change history we rectified
his dream
the pulling down of colston statue came
during a black lives matter protest in
the city less than two weeks after the
murder of george floyd in minneapolis
tensions in the city were high
the jury was shown cctv footage of the
defendants and others involved in the
pulling down and rolling of the statue
but in the end the jury sided with the
defense that bristol is better off
without the statue on this plinth that
was described during the trial as a
festering cancer in the city
the statue which has been on display in
a museum since last summer sparked a
nationwide debate over other
controversial monuments
some historians say its removal is
simply part of its history to see it
brought down
uh within the context of a
global protest about persistent forms of
racial inequality that find their roots
in
the history of slavery i think was an
extraordinary moment
for the supporters of the four on trial
this was the right result i think this
is just such a waste of money bringing
this prosecution uh to trial because uh
the people of bristol never wanted the
statue it feels like a very historic
moment bristol has had control of its
own narrative for too long i just took
the control out of bristol's hands
at the end of the two-week trial three
of the defendants left court wearing
t-shirts made by street artist banksy
he said the money raised was so they
could go for a pint for the so-called
colston four it is an historic night of
celebration dan whitehead sky news in
bristol